increased tensions between china and the
u.s following the house speaker nancy
pelosi's possible stop in taiwan while
on a congressional visit to four other
asian countries chinese officials have
threatened military action if pelosi
visits the island nation that china
claims is a part of its territory
christina raffini has the latest from
the white house christina good morning
good morning michelle u.s officials have
said look there's no reason for china
and the u.s to come to blows if pelosi
decides to go ahead with her stop on the
swing to asia that's scheduled to start
this weekend however china might feel
differently
i don't ever talk about my travel
because as some of you know it's a
security issue asked about her upcoming
trip to asia house speaker nancy pelosi
would not confirm reports it will
include a stop in taiwan where she would
be the highest ranking u.s official to
set foot on the island in more than 25
years
no one should under and should
underestimate the determination of
ability of more than 1.4 billion chinese
people to defend its national
sovereignty and territorial integrity
chinese officials have issued stark
warnings and threatened a possible
military response if pelosi goes ahead
with the visit
speaking by phone thursday president xi
jinping told president biden playing
with fire sets yourself on fire
according to a chinese readout of the
call the increased rhetoric
coming out of the chinese side is simply
not necessary the white house says it
does not control the speaker's travel
and she does not need or seek its
approval
well i i think that
the military thinks it's not a good idea
right now
but
i don't know what the status of it is
taiwan's independence has been a trigger
point in u.s chinese relations with
china alleging the self-governing island
is part of its territory and the u.s
pledging to help taiwan defend itself
but not outright supporting its
independence
our policy has not changed
the united states strongly opposes any
unilateral efforts to change the status
quo
or to undermine peace and stability
across the taiwan strait
and christina we also know that you've
been following the latest on the talks
between the u.s and russia on a
potential prisoner transfer what can you
tell us
that's correct secretary of state
anthony blinken who just saw there
talking about taiwan also spoke to his
russian counterpart sarri lavrov this
week for the first time since russia
invaded ukraine he wouldn't say however
if that conversation made this deal
which is a proposed prisoner swap is is
the what the reporting is on that any
more or less likely now there's an
additional report that russia has
requested another russian national be
returned in return for uh brittany
greiner and paul whelan the issue is
this russian national is not in u.s
custody they're in german custody
so an american official called that a
bad faith effort not to take the deal
that's on the table michelle
a lot to be looking at christina thank
you